salut c'est Juliette et aujourd'hui je
voulais vous raconter l'histoire de
Solène Solène elle souffre d'anorexie
depuis qu'elle a 13 ans et aujourd'hui
elle en a 18 ans
[Musique]
et du coup on s'était rencontré via zum
je peux juste te demander de décaler la
caméra ou toi un tout petit peu on a
fait une interview pour brut ensemble où
elle nous racontait un peu sa maladie
elle m'a raconté les moments difficiles
qu'elle avait traversé avec l'anorexie
mais à ce moment-là elle allait beaucoup
mieux quand la vidéo est sortie elle a
touché énormément de personnes et cela a
reçu des centaines de messages de
soutien on est resté en contact toute
l'année mais malheureusement en mai 2021
Solène a rechuté et en juin 2021 elle
est repartie à l'hôpital pour une
troisième fois elle porte une sonde
depuis 7 mois elle ne peut que aller en
cours deux fois par semaine parce que
sinon elle est trop fatiguée on ne sait
encore jamais rencontré parce que quand
je t'ai parlé c'était via zoom et
téléphone donc pour cette vidéo je suis
allée rencontrer Solène pour la première
fois
[Musique]
ça fait trop plaisir de voir en vrai
c'est trop cool
[Musique]
ok Nicolas je suis avec Solène je suis
dans le miroir derrière toi et là on est
en train de dire la dernière fois qu'on
a fait la vidéo c'était quand du coup le
19 février 2021 et aujourd'hui on est
quoi mais le 16 février 2022
et là on voit toutes les réactions
de mes amis qui avaient vu la vidéo
brute j'ai changé en un an
là
forcément
moins bien déjà physiquement je suis
plus la même ça fait depuis que j'ai 13
ans que je souffre de cette maladie et
j'en ai 18 aujourd'hui j'ai eu un
traumatisme quand j'avais 12 ans et je
pense que c'est le fait d'avoir pas
contrôler traumatisme qui a fait que
j'ai voulu contrôler quelque chose de
dans ma vie et quotidienne et ça a été
la nourriture
donc là bas mon petit café un petit
expresso mais par exemple le gâteau bah
j'ai pas mangé c'est un truc genre même
le sucre et tout bah je suis en mode now
dance ce qui est dur c'est que notre
propre médicament c'est nous-même comme
nous-même on est notre propre ennemi
dans la maladie
[Musique]
c'est comme si on était deux personnes
donc il y a le soleil de qui qui est
normal entre guillemets qui est pas
malade qui a envie de vivre qui a envie
de sortir d'aller mieux de faire ses
études après des psychologues ou d'être
professeurs ça je ne sais pas encore et
le soleil qui est malade qui me bouffe
littéralement en fait et de l'intérieur
comme de l'extérieur qui est constamment
là et qui prend plus partie dans ma vie
que l'eau de Solène normal entre
guillemets sont la maladie
[Musique]
personne te comprend c'est parce que
personne ne te comprend
je fais des Tik Tok et
les gens me disent
oh tu es belle tu es magnifique etc et
du coup après il y a d'autres
commentaires qui font mais non mais en
fait il faut pas que tu dis ça parce
qu'après elle va croire qu'elle est
belle et du coup elle va continuer dans
cette continuité d'être mal et d'être
maigre et d'être squelettique et c'est
moche
parfois il y a des filles qui mettent en
valeur leurs maigreur moi je le fais pas
enfin genre ou alors je le fais
inconsciemment mais enfin c'est juste
que moi je suis une fille donc cette
semaine normale entre guillemets a
toujours aimé être coquette se maquiller
être bien apprêté
pour sortir mais ce n'est pas pour toi
qu'elle s'est fait belles j'ai toujours
gardé ça même en étant malade et c'est
vrai que parfois justement ben ça peut
être pris comme une glamourisation
de l'anorexie alors qu'au final pas du
tout c'est juste prendre soin de soi
même dans le mal
[Musique]
c'est un combat tous les jours sur
comment manger combien de calories
combien d'heures je fais de sport
au lieu de travailler au lieu de sortir
avec ses potes c'est c'est être détaché
de du monde super de la vie en fait
c'est perdre toute vie normale
est-ce que tu prends une petite
courgette ou je sais pas tu as pris tes
médocs
il y a des troubles physiques clairs
pour le malade
il y a des souffrances physiques pour le
malade et il y a pardon
et c'est la psychiatre de Solène je peux
allô bonjour Docteur
avant voilà j'étais dans elle était à
l'hôpital elle est à la clinique elle va
sortir elle sera guérie et j'ai mis
beaucoup beaucoup de temps à comprendre
que cette maladie était extrêmement
sournoise qu'elle était imprévisible
c'est une maladie psychiatrique et on
n'en sait pas grand chose on voit les
conséquences on peut voir même un peu
les causes mais après il y a la réalité
de cette maladie et ça c'est
difficile la George prendre des
courgettes genre il y a deux il y a deux
semaines bah j'en prenais pas parce que
j'avais peur de ça entre guillemets
alors qu'en fait bah c'est rien c'est
juste genre légumes qui est bon pour toi
et tout et genre c'est juste le fait de
rajouter quelque chose dans mon
alimentation je pensais que j'allais
grossir alors qu'en fait pas du tout et
pour les proches ça peut c'est compliqué
aussi parce que il voit que j'avance
mais très très doucement
[Musique]
elle est pas drôle notre vie c'est
à aucun enfin aucun membre de la famille
tout le monde est on est tous
prisonnier et victime de
cette maladie c'est difficile de se
réjouir de même une fête de famille
un repas de Noël c'est compliqué
[Musique]
voyager c'est compliqué
voilà
tout tout est difficile
hop en fait c'est la machine et dedans
en fait vous avez
vous devez accrocher ça semaine porte
une sonde c'est un petit tuyau qui passe
du nez jusqu'à l'estomac et ça lui
permet de s'alimenter de manière
régulière et efficace
et là il y a le sac à dos pour l'école
et du coup bah je mets juste ça alors
j'ai lu j'ai celui des cours et aussi
j'ai mon déjeuner du coup j'ai trop ça
qui du coup tout le monde mais qu'est-ce
que tu fais avec trois sacs on dirait
que tu déménages ah non non c'est juste
ça ça du coup je vous ai expliqué et du
coup parfois c'est un peu gênant mais ça
va elle a toujours des moments de joie
de bonne humeur de gaieté mais
vous savez cet espace de petit impulsion
d'insouciance
qu'on devrait avoir quand on a 18 ans
elle ne l'a pas du tout ce côté
je fais ce que je veux je m'en fous de
la vie c'est sympa oh mes parents je les
emmerde je rentrerai quand je voudrais
des trucs que tous les ados font qui
mettent les parents en rage
mais qui n'arriveront pas ou qui ne se
produisent pas ici
en fait je me dis que la bouteille en
entier c'est trop alors que
[Musique]
je les mange cru des courgettes
mais ça change cru normalement
j'ai cru et en fait genre j'ai plus de
mal à m'imaginer manger des légumes
cuits parce que pour moi cuit bah du
coup tu dois rajouter des matières et
tout bah non juste tu mets dans la poêle
ouais si elle est pas si c'est une poire
le poil anti adhésif normalement tu as
même pas besoin de matière grasse cuit
tout ça
ce sera meilleur surtout et je pense que
ouais pour ton ventre peut-être meilleur
quand c'est cuit quoi
mais ouais je suis pas dans ma tête
c'est comme ça en vrai
littéralement et genre bah ça fait ça
fait bizarre au début au début je me
sens coupable de me dire que c'est bon
je me sens pas de motorisé à manger
alors qu'en fait bah c'est juste normal
en fait
mais
je suis fière d'avoir
rêvé au moins là
comment est la soupe
à chaque fois que je reprenais du poids
et que je recommençais à manger c'était
pour les autres pour ma famille pour mes
amis et en fait je me suis rendu compte
que c'était bien c'était bien mais
c'était pas suffisant que à chaque fois
en fait je rechutais parce que justement
la maladie me disait que je m'arrêtais
pas de guérir et on sait que parfois
elle essaye
mais enfin bon elle peut finir en larmes
parce que
pour aussi nous faire plaisir et nous
soulager elle va finir un bol de soupe
qu'elle s'était préparée et qui était
peut-être un peu important
voilà moi je l'ai vu pleurer à la fin
d'un dîner qui était très léger malgré
tout et elle finit le dîner en larmes et
elle quitte la table et elle va dans sa
chambre et elle pleure mais vraiment des
sanglots de douleur
donc c'est
assez incroyable de vivre ça je fais
souffrir mes proches énormément je sais
que bah forcément enfin je me fais
souffrir moi-même aussi mais pourtant je
continue à faire les choses qu'il faut
pas faire j'ai l'impression que ça va
apporter quelque chose mais en fait si
je suis fait mère et c'est juste
c'est faux en fait enfin c'est juste
ouais un faux semblant de quelque chose
en fait Solène c'est pas la seule à
vivre ce qu'elle vit la semaine passée
j'ai lancé une messagerie pour avoir un
peu vos retours et vos expériences sur
cette maladie et vous avez été très très
nombreux à me répondre
à un squelette et je me rappelle de
cette phrase qui m'a choqué qui m'a fait
un peu prendre conscience des choses et
moi j'espère pendant quatre ans ta
nourritif je suis passé par de
nombreuses
c'est maintenant la troisième fois que
je lance une messagerie pour une de mes
vidéos et j'ai jamais reçu autant de
messages en une journée j'ai été malade
pendant plus d'une dizaine d'années et
je pense d'ailleurs que c'est une
maladie qui fera partie de moi toute ma
vie comme Solène beaucoup de vos
messages témoignent de ce paradoxe de
l'anorexie on sait qu'on doit guérir
mais en même temps on en a pas vraiment
envie et même à la période où j'ai perdu
le plus de poids je n'arrivais pas à
voir images dans le miroir et qui est
terrible c'est qu'encore aujourd'hui
donner tout pour retourner à score là
alors je sais que c'est encore malade
depuis notre dernière rencontre Solène a
pu finalement retirer sa sonde c'est un
énorme part en avant par contre ça
présente plein de nouveaux problèmes
notamment le fait que maintenant elle
doit prendre du poids toute seule sans
l'aide de sa sonde qui lui apportait
environ 700 calories par jour
ça va ça va et toi du coup on est bac
avec Solène
c'est quoi la différence aujourd'hui que
il y a deux semaines j'ai vu la seconde
et ça fait comment bah ça fait du bien
je suis libre de moi-même donc tant
mieux
allô
voilà c'est bien mon espoir pour le
futur c'est que le processus dans lequel
Solène à mes yeux est en train d'entrer
va être un espèce de cercle vertueux
parce qu'on ne vit pas toute sa vie avec
une sonde parce qu'on ne vit pas toute
sa vie avec sa mère parce qu'on ne vit
pas toutes ces vies à voir une activité
deux jours par semaine et le reste du
temps seul dans une solitude atroce pour
une jeune fille de son âge
dans sa chambre voilà
des légumes des légumes ce qui est
mieux c'est
ne pas être focalisé sur sur la maladie
plus être focalisée sur ce que l'on veut
vraiment la Solène la vraie Solène
j'essaye d'aller mieux mais en même
temps j'ai envie de perdre du poids
encore j'ai encore du chemin à faire
mais je sais que je vais y arriver parce
que très bien entouré
si cette vidéo vous a intéressé vous
pouvez vous abonner à notre chaîne
YouTube pour voir d'autres portages et
n'hésitez pas à m'envoyer un message sur
Instagram si vous avez d'autres idées de
sujets les choses qui vous tiennent à
cœur
[Musique]